[Music]
thank you thank you I'm I'm sure that I
love you too I'm sure that thank you so
much
what an honor to be here that package
was that clip was real was unbelievable
just so you guys know I was backstage as
well like this and I it is an honor to
be here thank you
the great poet William Butler Yeats once
wrote how can we tell the dancer from
the dance now I've never obviously had
the honor of meeting the late great Gene
Kelly but from the very first time that
I ever saw the legendary dancer defying
gravity and forever defining grace and
of course singing in the rain I felt as
if I could tell exactly who Gene Kelly
was obviously Patricia said he was
someone else but
nevertheless I'm gonna live in the
fantasy of that but this man was and is
a genuine Hollywood legend and a master
poet in motion I think by any standard
he had all the right moves I come out
here and try a few of my own but we all
know that they would pale in comparison
and probably hurt myself and that would
not be good there's something genuinely
timeless about the greats on film and
they stay with us always because they
continue to move us time and time again
Gene Kelly was born 100 years ago that
ain't old you know I mean make no
mistake this remarkable remarkable
presence remains so vivid in the world
of film and dance especially for someone
like me and and he doesn't need a
hologram to do it so right didn't know
you guys went to Coachella
I will never assume the bandwidth of a
genre again gene was pure magic you know
he was he was graceful beyond compare
but also masculine and human and earthy
and true gene himself once said if Fred
Astaire is the Cary Grant of Dance
I'm the Marlon Brando
but I love that I love that quote and
I'll get to that in a second why it
means so much to me and what I feel like
I take from all of his performances but
I also know that he felt that too often
dancers and films didn't have the chance
to explore the emotional complexities of
their parts attic adequately so breaking
new ground for the genre that he came to
define so memorably had to have been so
important and I know that gene will live
on through the greatest film musicals of
all time like of course singing in the
rain I think perhaps the single most
iconic dance number of all time I think
we can I think we can agree on that but
also you know movies like on the town
the eternal Technicolor romance of an
American in Paris of course and like
we're like we're hearing tonight and and
and remembering and remembering that he
wasn't just seriously a great actor but
that he excelled behind the camera as
well as a choreographer a director
producer and though he could have a
charming carefree energy on camera
behind the scenes he was clearly a man
who cared passionately about all the
work that he did and if you could try to
imagine singing in the rain and on the
town without his brilliant direction
along with Stanley Donnan I who knows
what that film could have turned into
but I think he also artfully combined
choreography with animation like we saw
in Anchors Away special effects like a
covergirl and as Jean once explained he
tried to do things with dance that were
uniquely cinematic I think he coined the
phrase Cinna dancing and no one ever
sent a danced
like Gene Kelly so like so many before
me who work on stage and in film
I still look to Gene Kelly as one of the
most heroic examples of what could
actually be done in a movie I think I'm
also one of the millions who have
probably blatantly and and well slightly
unapologetically stolen a move or two or
three or four from Gene Kelly but I'm
cool with that
like I said because I feel like that
puts me in the company of guys like I
don't know Michael Jackson may have
heard of him - whatever
but jeans legacy is large and lasting
when he passed the New York Times
obituary pointed out that he quote
brought a vigorous athleticism casual
grace and earthy masculinity to the high
romance of the lavish Hollywood musical
in other words and why I love the quote
the Marlon Brando quote is and for me
he made the Hollywood musical not just
dance but sing and really speak to us
there were real real grounded
performances there he embodied ordinary
people who through the art of dance
could do extraordinary things that the
rest of us could only dream of and that
for me is why I'll remember Gene Kelly
the most and I think that's why we are
also forever blessed to know the dancer
and the dance thank you so much for
having me here thank you
[Applause]